There are two solutions for any given quadratic equation. Let's think back to
how this emerges from the quadratic formula. It comes out of the presence of
this plus or minus here in the numerator. This is going to give us two answers,
negative b plus the square root of b squared minus four a c all over two a, and
then the same thing except for a minus sign in between the negative b and the
rest of the numerator. This also makes sense if we look at the general form for
a quadratic equation as well. We have ax squared plus bx plus c equals 0 and in
order to end up with a term involving an x squared in it, because we know that
the coefficient a is not allowed to equal 0. We need to be able to multiply 2
things together that have a factor of x in them, since that's the only way you
can get an x squared down here. That means that either of these factors needs to
be able to be set equal to 0 and give us both solutions. So there are 2
solutions.